have since bear was little have had a
lot of alternative ways of raising him
that maybe the broader society kind of
looked at like what are you doing and i
even have seen like an article it's like
all the things that alicia silverstone
did does
that are that are terrible
i just do what's not i'm a natural mama
and i'm a loving mama and i believe in
love and i believe in nature and our
society is scared of nature and scared
of love
my son's dad
he and i did it together and because he
goes i love pigs too so we went we went
vegan and and you're right every
talk show made fun of me every time i
did an interview i was very young
and
i thought i hated being famous
so i really used it as an opportunity to
just talk about it but it was not a
calculated choice because
no one wants to hear about it unless
they're asking you about it and i didn't
really recognize that so they want to
talk about clueless and i'm talking
about anal electrocution of fur you know
that's not really
what they want to hear right so it
didn't go over very well i think for a
while but i think i found a way to
understand that you have to fill
yourself with joy and you have to be a
healthy happy person otherwise if you
like there was a time where i did every
single thing that somebody asked me to
do everything for activism and i was
just left with nothing
and
if we're not filled if our foundation
isn't good then i don't know how we can
serve others and so
i have learned that over time
[Music]
that was alicia silverstone i laughed a
lot in this conversation probably
because we've been friends for a while
so i feel really comfortable with her
but also because she's just so dang
funny alicia is charming witty and has
so much wisdom to share while
beautifully keeping her passions
lighthearted and filled with love and
joy
i'm guessing you already know who alicia
is but in case you don't she's an
actress best known for her iconic role
in the hit film clueless a movie i
diehard loved growing up
she's also a new york times best-selling
author health advocate co-creator of my
timed organic supplements and host of
the real heel podcast definitely tune
into her podcast if you haven't already
alicia is a wonderful mother to her son
bear and she's boldly and
unapologetically shared her passions for
natural living since the time she's been
in the spotlight even if it was met with
ridicule or laughter as a longtime vegan
she's published two incredible books
that were some of the first vegan books
of their kind in the kind diet she
shares all the secrets to attaining
truly radiant beauty with compassionate
and delicious recipes that are kind to
our planet and transforms your body from
the inside out
and the kind mama is a prescription for
a healthy vibrant pregnancy that will
help you take charge of your fertility
and grow the healthiest happiest baby
while you tap into your own powerful
motherly intuition
in this episode we talk about what it
was like for her to be vegan before it
was cool and being vegan in hollywood
her tips for raising healthy kids the
responses she receives from pushing back
against the normal and common parenting
what she's most excited about right now
and more alicia is happy for people to
think what they want about the way she
raises her child even if it raises
eyebrows because her alternative
parenting techniques work for her family
which have included co-sleeping
elimination communication her son's long
hair teaching her son to question
everything he's told raising him vegan
not punishing him and many more so sit
back and laugh with us as we chat about
all the above welcome to the ellen
fisher podcast welcome to the podcast
alicia i'm so excited to have you on the
show and honors so thank you for i would
say thank you for being here but i'm at
your place
thank you so much i'm so glad that you
guys came over and all the little babies
are here i know i want to eat them all
all of our kids like i mean bear and our
kids like just get along so well
and they just love you because you're
just so good with kids i feel like the
way you speak to them they just feel
like you're really listening to them and
engaging so they like you know they can
tell a huge difference
when someone's like not interested like
oh that's a child i'm not yes then
versus like you're a person i want to
talk to you yes
it's true it's true they're so sweet we
i think we parent very similarly
so it's like it's just another auntie
yes and last time we were here scout was
just a baby yes so you hadn't even met
cofax yet no and i told scout upstairs i
said when you were a baby i got to
babysit you she said oh that's right
yeah we did we like went out to dinner
you did but she was a big baby so it's
weird that she's now
like she's a little girl yeah but she
was a big baby yeah she was
shooting me so she
yeah it doesn't make sense because you
haven't seen them in like three years
then they like stretch out they stretch
out they're getting taller
so funny okay so i first want to ask you
my first like burning question is what
was it like to be vegan before it was
cool to be vegan like how long have you
been vegan you literally were vegan
before it was like like where did you
even get your books and resources back
then like your book the kind diet was
like one of the first cool vegan books
even out there and the way that i know
that is because i was working at a
health food store
um
years ago and they had like a book
section like a health section and your
book was one of the few vegan books in
the beginning like this was like
15 years ago thank you for saying that
that makes me happy
um
because it was needed and that's why i
did it i never do anything
everything takes too much work so i
would never do anything if it wasn't
needed
you know i mean that's such a good
launch like i have no interest in yeah
i'd much rather just be on vacation and
hang out and do my acting here and there
and but no it was needed so back when i
became vegan
what book did i well i didn't do it
because of i didn't read a book what
happened was i
you know saw
there was a few things i had a dog that
i fell in love with samson and he would
sleep with me he would we basically made
out you know he was like my boyfriend
and
he was this big black roddy pity labby i
don't know what he was but
he was so beautiful and i would rub his
legs and i could remember feeling his
legs and thinking it felt like a chicken
breast
and that connection was sort of and i
thought well i bet my thigh tastes good
too
it's like i bet my butt tastes real good
i'll process so
that sort of started happening but when
i was the truth is i was eight years old
when i wanted to go vegan i was in
england with my family and my mom i'd
heard the crying of the i heard these
this deep deep crying
and i asked what is this to the farmer
and they said oh well the babies are
being taken away from their mothers
i said why
and they explain well that's how you get
milk
and this was i was eight so it's hard to
kind of process the whole thing but then
i knew that did not sit well with me
then i got on the airplane flying home
from england because we go for the
summers my brothers started making the
sound of the lamb that i was eating
and that was my first awareness that
lamb was lamb
and this really freaked me out so i came
home and i declared i was going
vegetarian but i was eight and i really
didn't know what i was doing so um
my dare my dear dad did buy me a book
but not a book anyone wants to read
you know like some
how to be vegetarian but it was i was
eight and your book was for
like 15 year olds or an adult it just
wasn't speaking to me
but anyway so i tried from eight to
twenty one i would sort of what i call
flirting in the kai diet is i would go
in and out of it and i'd be vegan or
vegetarian i didn't know about vegan yet
i'd be vegetarian and then somebody be
eating a steak and i'd have my eye on it
because i loved the taste it wasn't a
question of not liking the taste
you gonna eat all that
it made me like no do you want some well
when you're done i'll eat it when you're
done and i would i'd be the cleanup
group it's like the same thing like when
you go on a date and you order the salad
but your partner orders the fries and
you're like i don't want you guys but
then you see it you're like you just
want a little yeah just a little
so i would do that and then when i was
21 i was i had a meeting with peta and i
often worked with i worked with peta
from 15 to 21 and when i um
when i was having this one meeting with
them
i was so activated by what i was
learning about the pigs and the cows and
i was just why aren't you doing this and
why aren't you doing that and
you know as you do when you want
somebody else to take care of everything
and you see it's so righteous right like
this is terrible it has to stop what are
you doing yeah and as i was driving away
i thought what am i doing i'm still
eating these creatures so i went v i
came home and my husband my son's dad my
husband at the time
he and he and i did it together and
because he goes i love pigs too so we
went we went vegan and and you're right
every talk show made fun of me every
time i did an interview they
you know i made the
i made the um it was very young
and
i thought i hated being famous
so i really used it as an opportunity to
just talk about it but it was not a
calculated choice because
no one wants to hear about it unless you
unless you're they're asking you about
it and i didn't really recognize that so
they want to talk about clueless and i'm
talking about anal electrocution of fur
you know that's not really
what they want to hear right so it
didn't go over very well i think for a
while and i really started to learn from
people like howard lyman
and i saw the movie the witness
um which is a great movie about this
brooklyn guy who hated animals but he
fell in love with this girl or he wanted
to get with this girl so he by accident
became an animal lover because of her
it's a really good movie anyway these
movies and
talking to other activists like howard
lymon
he really inspired me that you have to
be the example you have to wait for
people to come to you and ask
and boy that makes it so much easier
because then you're not using so much
energy everywhere you go
i remember my husband used to be like
can you just go to a party and not talk
about your food can we just do you have
to tell everybody about the horror and i
was like but it's
to me everything was rape murder
fire like everything how can we not be
screaming this and i still have that
feeling about many different subjects
but i think i've found a way to
understand that you have to fill
yourself with joy and you have to be a
healthy happy person otherwise if you
like there was a time where i did every
single thing that somebody asked me to
do everything for activism and i was
just left with nothing
and
if we're not filled if our foundation
isn't good then i don't know how we can
serve others and so
i have learned that over time yeah i
think burnout is a real thing yeah right
and so you can have this fire inside of
you to want to for the cause but then if
you're not taking care of yourself and
finding balance in that way like you're
not going to last very long exactly and
then it's not very fruitful either
because it's true i think a lot of
people experience what you just said
like especially in the beginning when
they first learn about the horrors of
what's happening in the animal
agriculture industry and they go vegan
and they're like i mean i definitely had
this and i would go tell people and i'm
like you guys don't like did you know
this like don't you want to go vegan now
and then be like nah and i'm like
how like i could i couldn't comprehend
it which is funny though because then i
wasn't really into how how i once wasn't
vegan too and i actually used to make
fun of vegans too when i was in high
school like i mean i didn't really know
what it was but you know junior high or
yeah junior high high school area
age if somebody like mentioned something
about being vegetarian or vegan it was
like oh gosh those people not really you
know yeah and then look at me today so
you know just like being understanding
and then just everyone's on their own
journey and also waiting for people to
come to you because you can't change
anyone's mind like everyone is going to
change their own mind on their own terms
yeah and you actually push people
further away i think so and i i did i
mean there were some people that would
tell me oh i read this article we were
talking about it and you go oh well
thank god somebody but but it's also
just
i think at the end of the day um
[Music]
the proof is in the pudding i mean what
happened to me when i went vegan when i
stopped just yelling at everybody about
it was that um
you know my skin changed my hair changed
my nails changed i got off my asthma
inhaler i stopped taking allergy shots
twice a week my body slimmed up all my
cystic acne went away my whites of my
eyes got really white you know you could
not bend my nails anymore they were so
brittle before so and i stopped needing
to go to the doctor i stopped needing
medication i stopped needing anything
and that was so powerful
and i think that that is something that
you know when people would say to me wow
you're glowing like what's happening
with you and that was really exciting to
me because i didn't know that that was
what was going to happen i did it for
the animals yeah
but what happened to me was this
incredible health awakening and i would
never
have taken my health seriously i didn't
have the self-worth to take myself to
take my health seriously
um at that age i was just much more like
if you're gonna tell me that i need to
be healthy you're telling me i'm fat and
you can
you know what i mean that's that was my
reaction i was 19 and 20 and 21 like
don't tell me about my body don't tell
me about my health just leave me alone
so it was the animals that saved me
really and um
yeah i think that you asked what it was
like before i think i i've i've
withstand withstood a lot of criticism
a lot of mocking
um
but the cool thing is is i always knew i
when you know you're doing something
that's right it doesn't really matter
ultimately it can be painful for sure
it's always painful to put your neck out
and be it's
but when you know that you are part of
something that is part of the solution
and not part of the problem like how can
you not want to continue
right and you just know the end you know
the end goal you know like it will
change over time you like almost had a
deep knowing about it you're like oh
yeah well just wait yes because you know
that it's the truth yes so when did you
take your self you said you didn't have
self-worth back then like when did you
start shifting was it at that time when
you went vegan like i know you saw those
results but when did you start feeling
self-worth as like a valuable thing to
consider i think it was part of
the diet makes eating clean healthy food
which also happens to be
free of cruelty
um you know the plant-based diet
i think just all of i think my heart
soft i think there's a
there's when you're eating meat dairy
and sugar and all this stuff i mean look
i still eat sugar i try really hard not
to but i'm not gonna say i'm perfect
it still finds its way
but um
but when that's like just normal and
that's just the way you eat you know the
way normal people eat all the time
when you go we went to legoland
recently
and when you have are forced to eat the
way america usually eats
for a day we ate that way for i think
two days
i mean bear came home and puked like you
know and you go
how do people do this on the daily this
is normal this is just normal so
my point what's my point that that i
think that there's a sort of hardening
that happens or a there's [ __ ] there's
so much [ __ ] inside that needs to be
removed and
and once that starts happening that
detox process you can feel your body
more you can feel your heart more you
feel your intuition i remember people
used to say well just listen to your
body and like listen to my body how do
you listen to your body but oh my god do
i listen to my body and net you know now
you start to be able to everything
softens and you're living in your intuit
you're living in your in your truth
and you are aligned with your principles
so you're not doing something because i
remember eating animals and still trying
to say i was a good person and still
trying to say i was an animal lover and
that was that was a that was tricky for
me from from the age eight to 21 where i
would sort of like but i'm an animal
lover and i'm an animal activist and i
love animals but i'm eating them okay
interesting you know we'll just ignore
that just ignore that you're still good
you're still good
and so when i was able to go no no this
is wrong and i'm not gonna do it anymore
and stand in that truth um i think that
there's a super
there's clarity that comes with that
and also the power of standing up for
yourself even though i'm standing up for
the animals i don't think i could have
stood up for myself but i was able to
stand up for the animals and i think
that gave me a sense of self in that it
was important that i do that and um
and then over time i just started to
really
learn to take care of myself and learn
that i was important i was important if
i was going to if
in order to help them i had to take care
so i'm really all it's all good karma
because of the animals really i'm so
grateful to them for
for allowing me to find a way to really
truly love myself and take care of
myself and understand that i'm important
too and i'm an animal too yes right
all right guys are you looking for more
plant-based recipes to add into your
life and nourish your family i'm doing a
special ebook promotion for my podcast
listeners to thank you for all of your
support where you can get any of my
ebooks for 15 off with the code podcast
just go to ellen fisher.com ebooks and
enter the code at checkout to get this
deal while it lasts all three of my
ebooks are filled with our family's
favorite and staple plant-based recipes
that are whole foods focused nourishing
delicious and satisfying many of these
recipes we eat on a weekly or even daily
basis and it's filled with the meals
that i found over the years to make my
family feel our best taste incredible
and most of them are quick to whip up in
the kitchen too a family favorite is the
vegan lasagna in my epic vegan cravings
ebook and also you have to make a big
batch of home baked omega granola which
is sure to get eaten within the week
healthy hummus recipes and a totally
decadent springtime lemon poppycake
layered with strawberry jam and cream
cheese frosting made from coconut and
lemon zest that the kids love for me to
make for their birthdays the linguine
parm and veganzuki which is a chocolate
chip skillet cookie topped with the
healthiest homemade vanilla ice cream
that tastes like it's from a creamery is
to die for and i love making for family
dinner every week the hearty red lentil
chili from the epic plant bear kid food
ebook these ebooks are 100 vegan whole
foods focused gluten-free friendly and
are instant digital downloads that can
be read on any smartphone tablet or
computer between all three ebooks i also
include practical tips encouragement
inspiring content simple swaps to
enhance the health of your meals a
seven-day sample meal plan how to help
your children love fruits and vegetables
lunchbox ideas beginner vegan tips and
more and i have poured my heart and soul
into these books between all three
ebooks there's over 460 pages of content
and vibrant photography and each recipe
is filled with vibrant whole plant foods
for health and wellness in both body and
mind remember to use the code podcast at
checkout for 15 off any or all of my
ebooks i hope you enjoy them and feel
inspired to get in the kitchen to make
healthy nourishing plant-based meals and
yeah the cause and effect and it's
almost like one cause of this and it's
just like a spiral and it keeps going
and yeah there's so many benefits i know
that i definitely experienced that
softening when i first went plant-based
it was for my health yeah and i had no
interest in hearing about the animals
you know at all
at all like literally i have so many
experiences like they're like oh do you
care that i mean the steak like and i'm
like i literally don't care because i
just it was just i was like just doing
this for me my temple it was just for me
and my tumble yeah and then once i
watched a gary yourofsky's speech the
best speech you'll ever hear i don't
have you ever seen that no you haven't i
was like crying and bawling by the end
of it he's a vegan activist
um and just i couldn't believe that i
never considered the animals before yeah
and
and then that's when that activism thing
within me was like i gotta tell
everybody yeah you know because before
then it wasn't like that but i think my
heart was softened to that message but
where it wouldn't have been before if i
wasn't already eating plant-based no i
love those stories i love when people
come to it for their health yeah it's
beautiful it's beautiful that you had
the worst
and the the whereabouts to know that you
mattered and you could make that choice
for yourself and that it was the right
choice and then
you softened into a lovey mushy yeah and
it all just fell into play yeah for sure
and then learning about the environment
and all that and like later as it just
like originally going you like have this
one reason and then later it's like wow
it's like so many reasons so many
reasons like you said same with me in
regards to my health taking off healing
so many
factors of my inner health my mindset
and just my body and so then then
learning about the animals i'm like guys
there's literally no reason not to do
this why why would you not want to but
like you said it really has to you have
to let people come to you just be the
example so going back to hollywood
what has it been like being vegan in
hollywood over the years you said you
got made fun of a lot you know articles
whatever but i love that you've always
just like stuck to your guns and just
been yourself and even just the way you
describe
um like how your dog was your boyfriend
like
i feel like you you say things like this
and then it makes it into the media like
look at what elysee has said
yeah so what's it been like being vegan
in hollywood especially the way that
hollywood portrays vegans even though
there's actually a lot of people who are
vegan in hollywood it seems like i don't
know how hollywood portrays vegans my
perception is we're very cool right now
because kim kardashian's vegan beyonce
is vegan jay-z's vegan i mean we've
taken over the world so um i don't i'm
not sure that um
you probably have a better perception of
it than i do i would i don't know if i
would i mean i didn't know that i didn't
know any of those people were vegan yeah
i know a lot of people are vegan and
there's way more than that and there's
ones that are vegan for their health and
they're not talking about it because
it's just for their health and there's
ones that care very much about the earth
and animals i know miley cyrus is often
vegan i don't know how vegan but she's
pretty vegan veganish and that's all we
need is a bunch of veganish people we
don't need them to all be perfect any
steps going in the right direction
but i think my my thoughts about being
in hollywood is like the way that in
movies portrays vegans as like what do
you make annoying yeah making fun of it
yeah yeah that's very annoying
i don't like that yeah i remember seeing
saturday live sketches and wanting to
call them and be like you guys what
you're saying is wrong
it's all good and it's supposed to be
fun right like things are there's going
to be comedy right yes for sure
for sure
um
you do i think
i mean i think that it's come so far
when i started
really jay leno looked looked at me like
i was an alien and he was so amused by
it like vegan
what like and let her do the same thing
they had their own way of doing it but
both of them it was a fun sketch for
them to talk about how i was this funny
little vegan thing and what is that and
not know how to pronounce it and no one
in the mainstream was saying that word i
know so it was sort of like vegan vegan
like what are you
and um and trying to explain it to them
and i feel very very proud that i was
able to bring it to the mainstream you
were so pivotal actually i think a lot
of people don't even realize how pivotal
you were like in that like being like
one of the first people making it to
where it's getting out that information
like oh there's somebody who's begging
what is that
well actually the animal rights
conference that happens they invited me
to receive an award because of bringing
it to the mainstream they were like you
are doing this
and then while i was there i gave this
speech and i got booed off the stage by
all the vegan by all the animal
activists because not all of them it was
a particular group but it was a really
funny experience and i thought you guys
this is where you go wrong because if i
wasn't so committed you'd lose me
like take any one of the people you know
there's a lot of actresses who are vegan
for a little bit and then they stop and
then they're vegan and they stop
right so those ones if they had shown up
at animal rights conference 2000 and got
booed off the stage they would be out
yeah like i don't want to be part of
this right so it's like what are you
guys doing
why were they booing you they were mad
at me because i said in my i decided and
it is obnoxious of me
totally obnoxious but i also knew what i
was talking about but still
i was trying to say that some tactics
didn't work as well as others and that
we should really focus on education and
kindness and
making ourselves um more
you know uh
more um what's the word
like accessible and attractive to the
other people because if we're going out
there and i was talking about sort of
throwing blood on people or causing
these fusses that these that that's not
that all they can do is say well those
crazy people yeah
what i
and i think certain people in that
audience thought i was talking about
them but i was really talking about a
different group and so it was this
misunderstanding um of what what i was
trying to say but i had to exit the
stage
and all of the heads of
of court came with me to my room to take
care of me while all these letters kept
flooding under the door it was so weird
and funny and um i wish i could i mean
it's a funny memory from my past that i
was in this room with alex hart alex
hershaft
wayne pacelli
um who else was in the room with me
probably paul shapiro do you know all
these people these are all vegan
warriors
but they were all from different you
know it was like humane society of the
us and it was um anyway so we were all
in there together and they were sort of
also alex pacello pacheco i can't
remember his last name but anyway they
were sort of saying no it's good what
you're saying and it's okay yeah that is
a very good message but it was it was
for some reason being booed it was so
booed that i it wasn't a mild boo it was
like you have to exit the building
and it was by the people that i speak
that i'm with so it was very interesting
like you're like hey i'm on your side
i'm on your side i'm just suggesting
that we all be but i can i'm sure it
sounded obnoxious who knows but it was
just sort of saying that one way was
better than another way and and i do
understand that we need all the ways
i don't know i don't know if we need the
dumping like blood on other people way
well what i learned yeah i mean well i
don't think it's okay to have a line i
think that what i told you
right now it's okay it's definitely
gonna come for me too
i learned over time that some of the
ways
while they don't look like they work to
us you know because
from my point was being a vegan you're
making it hard for me because everywhere
i go i have to fight against this label
right everyone wants to say to you oh
well peta sucks peter does this peter
you know it's like stop being can you
just stop doing that so we can make it
easier
yeah and what i learned with time was
that that's not actually that a lot of
what especially with peta for example
they make such change and
they would tell me well having a bunch
of girls be naked doing a
a thing gets attention
whereas the article you write for pcrm
if it doesn't have a celebrity attached
to it no one's going to listen a doctor
writing a piece is not going to make it
into the thing so you have to choose how
do we get this message out there so yes
we do shenanigans to get attention but
we get attention and it's proof is
they're not wrong in that when i did my
i did a naked wool campaign and i did a
naked um
uh and i never make it in movies so this
was for me a big deal that is a big deal
to show my body uh in was only for the
animals and i did it for uh pita for um
what was the first one just go vegeta i
think go vegan or go vegetarian whatever
and they said that just by doing that
the amount of people are for wool the
amount of people that click in and ask
for information is massive so it's it
has an effect while you well meanwhile
everyone's saying ban that video when i
did the go vegetarian video they wanted
all the news channels wanted to ban this
video of me
because they were saying it was indecent
and they were saying because it's really
probably because of the meat and dairy
industry they didn't want
that message being out there but in
unfortunately for their sake it got so
much more attraction because it was
banned
so everyone clicked on it yeah then they
want to see it more then they and then
not only do they click on it it got
peta got people asking for vegetarian
pamphlets
so it works yeah that's what i've
learned wow that's interesting so you
see both sides i see but you make a
really valid point that like if you're
quote-unquote side because you know the
the mindset of our like social and
cultural need to like be
feeling welcomed like for someone who
isn't like as strong of a vegan as you
like if you're like hey guys i care
about this too like i want to be part of
it and then you're like getting booed or
you're getting all this like you're
doing like i don't know mad at you
you're not doing it well enough or
whatever like people like i don't want
to be part of that group right i don't
want to be labeled at all and that does
happen like i know a lot of people who
are plant-based and maybe not like quite
as like ethical vegan as like others but
they still care about the animals but
they're like i don't want to be labeled
a vegan yeah because i don't be
associated with that because of things
like that that you just said yeah so
that's why i think i think you made a
pretty valid point it's probably
necessary
well zach bush just said to me on my
podcast he said i said you're v you're
vegan right zach and he goes i'm not i
don't like to be
called anything and i said why and he
goes because we are bigger than that we
are beings of light
it's like okay fair point but i do
happily identify as vegan even though
sometimes i'm not vegan sometimes i mess
up i'm still vegan i will still always
be vegan because it is
it is this thing
that
that holds so much um
i don't know i'm so proud yeah of
being able to make changes like
everywhere we go there's something we
can do to make this world better yeah
and most people are walking around
unconscious just not considering any of
those things and so when we can wake
them up to hey you could do this hey you
could do this how you could do this why
wouldn't we want that and he wants that
too yeah he just likes to for himself he
says yes i eat plant-based but i don't
call myself anything yeah i see i see
both sides like i actually just recently
recorded an episode with this guy named
pc serna you would love him i don't know
if you know he is but there was a whole
section in the podcast when we were
talking about labels and he was saying
when you use labels you limit you limit
yourself you immediately limit yourself
to how the person can receive you yeah
because they have their own biases and
cognitive feelings about the word and
there's so many charged words like
democrat republican you know like
anything christian catholic muslim all
these different things and then vegan
carnivore like oh yeah and then everyone
has their own set of biases based on
their own experiences and lenses of what
that means yeah and then they instantly
like judge you or not even
consciously judge you but subconsciously
perceive you in a certain way so i'm
like okay i see that but i'm the same as
you i'm like there's certain there are
certain things
that are to me i like having a label for
like i'm like i like being called vegan
and when i talk to someone who's like
well i don't want to be part of that
group because then people are going to
think i'm like this and i'm not like
that i'm like well that's exactly why
i'm even more like i'm vegan to kind of
break that stereotype to be like look
i'm not like that and i am vegan yeah so
yeah but there are certain things that's
like i especially think it's not helpful
when people put labels on you that you
didn't put on yourself yes that is the
worst because you're like i'm not even
putting that label on myself yeah so
yeah and i think that we don't want to
be constricted by the thing because it's
like i said i'd rather everyone just be
trying yeah than not trying at all
because they think they have to be
perfect to be in that club there's no
perfect it's just try yeah more and more
then the earth will thank you the
animals will thank you the star nine
million
children and people who die of hunger a
year will thank you
and your body will thank you so yeah i
think it's just worth trying as hard as
you can yeah and just do something
anything anything better than nothing
yeah yeah that's something that colleen
patrick grujo talks about i told you
about her yeah i did an episode with her
anyways okay next question i want to ask
you moving on a little bit is what are
your like plant-powered kid tips on like
raising healthy kids
um
well
what are my tips i
you know i think making delicious food
for sure
and
and also when they're little i really
tried hard when bear was little not to
introduce junk so there was no
you know he didn't have sugar for so
long and then he didn't have um you know
chips and things like that and he
he was very macrobiotic and and until he
because now that he's 11
you know
all bets are off it's harder so and i
don't mean that he's suddenly eating but
sometimes like this morning he
he said something to me about what he
wanted and i said he's obsessed with
talkies do you know about these takis no
okay well they are total trash it's
forgive me takis but who cares they're
gross it's like
oh i know when we were at his school
thing and he comes over he goes mommy
look these doritos they have poison in
them because they saw some stuff and i
go they definitely have poison in them
that's not the poison it's just they are
disgusting they are chemicals and
nastiness
and he was like okay mommy
but you know they the point is is now
he's eating
he has access to more junk in his life
and he can feel the difference he knows
what it feels like so i guess what i'm
saying is building a great foundation he
he was conceived
by a vegan healthy mama he was um
breastfed with healthy
nourishing foods and then his first
foods and all of his foods until he was
like three or four
were just brown rice beans and veggies
and then you know when they start to now
he's having i don't know
i give him a lot of choice too baby do
you want to have tacos tonight or do you
want to have a stir fry now they're both
comprised of the same things beans rice
and vegetables
so i'm getting what i need but it's him
having a choice which thing he'd rather
have and
i did get told recently i've been making
too many stir fries
at 11 it's been 11 years so it's fair
yeah can you mix it up trying to mix it
up so um
but the stir fries are such a great
thing because you can do you know i just
do kale beans and brown rice um and then
you know lots of he liked garlic in it
and
lots of lemon and a little shoyu and
you know and i make oatmeal for
breakfast sometimes but that's he's
gotten over that one now we have a lot
of mochi we have mochi which is so
delicious and um that's the rest there's
a recipe in my book for that
and um
what else do we have you know avocado on
toast and he's not he's not a big
smoothie guy but sometimes i try to get
a smoothie in him but yeah he doesn't
really care i think the foundation
aspect is so key because when they start
out on these really nourishing healthy
plant foods and as they get older and as
they're like becoming more autonomous
making their own choices and stuff
they'll you know they might dabble but
then they really see the difference and
they're like oh this and you can and
education yes i mean like look you know
these are like healthier foods these are
less healthy more nutritious more this
and explaining specifically why certain
foods are have these nutrition within
them that's so good for you yes and then
they gravitate towards that choice for
themselves and it's very empowering
because they're like look i'm supporting
my body i wish i knew any of that stuff
when i was a kid i had no idea yeah and
then by the time i hit puberty and i'm
like whoa my body's changing and like
i'm starting to i can't just eat
anything that i want now but i had no
foundation to understand like how to eat
healthy yeah and then that's where the
problems arise with like you know i
remember
in high school on our breaks me and my
friend kesley we would always share like
a snickers bar and hot flaming hot
cheetos and it's like sorry and i never
felt good after and i was like why don't
i feel good when i eat this
i don't understand
because i didn't know we didn't know
that's just how we stop at taco bell on
the way home you know like all that
stuff so
that foundation is so key i think and
like having lots of healthy foods in the
house yes um as the foundation right and
then they start out that way and then as
they get older they can make the choices
for themselves but
what i've seen at least with my kids is
that they gravitate towards the
healthiest like they you know have fun
with the snack stuff and yeah we like to
dabble in like the fun process vegan
snacks too yes but then they have that
and then they always want to go back to
the healthy foods yeah we're brought to
you today by anema mundi herbals an
apothecary shop specializing in high
potency elixirs medicinal mushrooms and
collagen boosters owned and operated by
a master herbalist from costa rica their
project educates and supports true fair
trade practices beyond organic farming
education and small farmers to create
remedies that benefit people from all
walks of life i'm obsessed with their
happiness powder which is an energizing
and mood boosting herbal coffee that is
caffeine free and adaptogenic i like it
served warm with plant milk and maple
syrup and it contains key herbal allies
that we like to call happy herbs other
immunity boosters in their shop include
black elderberry syrup mushroom mocha
milk and spirulina an organic protein
rich mineralizer that tastes delicious
in banana mango smoothies but my
favorite items in their shop tend to my
feminine and pregnant body halogen
booster face oil womb tea which is
perfect for pregnancy and a rose body
oil which is just divine anemomundi uses
eco-friendly packaging in recyclable
glass or biodegradable bags i got an
awesome discount code for you guys too
so you can enjoy this wonderful brand
use my code ellen15 for fifteen percent
off anything at anemamoodyherbals.com
that's a n i m a m u n d i h e r b a l s
dot com i think it's really important to
recognize that it is our responsibility
i think that um i was talking to someone
and they were saying you know
that there was some
that if you put cake in front of
children if you give them sort of a
plate of regular a vegan food or no any
food if you give them a pl they weren't
talking about veganism they were talking
about just food and kids and that
naturally if you give them a plate of
food and cake at the same time that the
kid's not gonna choose the cake i was
like you don't have a kid
that is not a true statement i'm so
sorry
like
i'm so sorry
maybe when they're three yeah it depends
on the age the age and what they've
already been introduced to but but five
and on yeah you put carrot sticks or
cakes come on what do you think they're
gonna fit even for us think about us
like of course if you're in you're
you're having a really good day you're
gonna make the right choices but on a
day before your period if somebody goes
hey here's some really yummy vegan
brownies you're not gonna say no
i mean at least i'm not no i'm not so so
i'm never gonna say no i love vegan
brownies right so my point is
come on like we have a responsibility to
build this foundation for our children
so that they can i really think giving
them healing nourishing food on the
daily and yes playing and letting them
go off and have the stuff that we go oh
i can't believe they're having that
it's okay it's okay i mean i don't hold
it and i just go ew okay fine yeah right
but he knows that i'm not like excited
about it but i also let him because why
not
but
ultimately
i know that they're not no i don't think
any of us
are fully
equipped some are but most people don't
have that kind of willpower to make the
you know even to go to bed on time we
all know that if we go to bed at 10 30
we're gonna have a way better day the
next day but can you put your phone down
can you stop your work can you stop your
project no
sometimes you can't we all have problems
with discipline right so to imagine to
expect a little child to be able to do
that for themselves and regulate their
choices is insanity and you can see it
you see the people who just go left
there have kids have whatever they want
well those kids have really dark circles
under their eyes they're usually quite
chubby they don't feel good and they're
acting up right the biggest thing that i
can say about feeding your kid the way
that you and i fed our kids
is they don't have this they're
regulated so they feel good inside
because they're pooping right yeah
because they're you know they're
sleeping well because there isn't all
this activation happening imagine when
your body goes to bed at night
and you've had all this horrible food
it's just trying to process it and
figure out what to do so rest is not
really happening and then when they make
up the next day they've got that
hangover from that sleep and all that
nasty food and now they've got to get it
up and do it all over again and so
they're just riding this kind of
unwellness and it's it makes you cranky
if i eat a bunch of junk i feel cranky
too
so i really see
that the amazing thing that happens with
my baby is he's got this very smooth
temperament you know he is not activated
he's not having um
he doesn't have big spurts of
he's not irrational yeah he's not um
they talked about the terrible twos in
terms of threes he didn't go through
that he was a very balanced healthy boy
and with tons of energy and tons of
strength so there's no weakness he's
like a wild man but that wild energy is
also grounded in a sort of
healthy presence so
i just see the proof is always in the
pudding and how they are and um
i'm so grateful you know he hasn't had
any he hasn't needed medicine and he's
11 years old same with all my kids none
of them have ever needed to go to the
hospital yeah and you're not
holding it back from them no they just
haven't they're just not needing it they
haven't needed it people think when we
say this that um oh it's because you
know you're not giving them medicine
when they need it no it's because
they're not sick yeah yeah that's why
literally they might get a stuffy nose
or a tiny cotton but they're still
climbing up a tree oh yeah seriously i
know
i totally feel you and then the
long-term benefits for that because how
many of us when since we didn't have
healthy foundations once we got older
you know because we can't blame our
parents they didn't know right when the
processed foods came out like there was
no information that like mcdonald's was
not
optimal
you know like when when i was young you
know like my parents had no idea i
remember one time actually we were
driving through this uh burger king
after wild rivers and my mom got us
burgers we're like thanks mom these are
so good and she's like you know so and
so at this
this place that she knows someone um
was she said so-and-so doesn't give her
kids any fast food and we're like what
oh my gosh she's like i know i don't
know
she was so pretty she's like so proud i
get you fast food we're like thanks mom
and then here i am years later i can't
believe that and then here i am years
later like i'm that mom
but the foundation
of having like we're going back to
because how many people didn't have that
healthy foundation that when you get
older you start to experience symptoms
and things that happen from how you how
you were raised when you were younger so
many different factors right oh yeah and
it sets you up for a better success as
you get older after you go through
puberty and you're just less likely to
oh yeah have a problem this doesn't mean
that you're going to be superhuman and
you're never going to have anything like
being realistic about your health is so
i think pivotal um but there's the
factor of having a set of well
foundation just sets you up for life it
does it really really does yeah i
remember witnessing this one actress who
was telling me that her kids that they
all nobody slept that they all had
insomnia that everyone was like jacked
up that no one could sleep she needed to
go to sleep camp everything was a mess
and i was watching her now granted we
were at a party so it's not entirely
fair because of course you're gonna be
indulging at a party but the kids were
shoving
cupcake after cupcake in their mouths
and i said i'm i know where to party
today so this makes sense but
have you considered
just as a friendly suggestion after
hearing her for 20 minutes tell me about
how sleep-deprived she was and her
children were and how you know aggro
everything was and she was losing her
mind i said have you considered you know
just removing some sugar she's looked at
me she goes sugar doesn't have anything
to do with it
[Laughter]
so you have a lot of alternative you
have since bear was little have had a
lot of alternative ways of raising him
that maybe the broader society kind of
looked at like what are you doing and i
even have seen like an article it's like
all the things that alicia silverstone
did does
that are that are terrible
so anti like not status quo
so maybe we can get into a little bit of
those like you co-slept and things like
that
yeah i just do what's not i'm a natural
mama and i'm a loving mama and i believe
in love and i believe in nature and our
society is scared of nature and scared
of love
and so that right there that's the whole
podcast i think that's it i mean they
they are they react as if
it's okay with women to be naked on the
beach i don't mean naked like on a naked
beach i mean with a string up their bum
as a bathing suit and like no bathing
suit that's okay
but a woman can't breastfeed that is
very interesting and i'm just like what
why is it okay for women to be
sexualized on in on a beach or in the in
our movies or whatever and on a
billboard or in videos like magazines
just coming anything yeah but we can't
gently feed our children with the thing
that was made to feed them like what is
wrong with you
i know that is very weird so that's you
know one thing then there's all these
other cultures and all these other
people that do it the things i'm doing
i'm not inventing
i didn't invent any of it you would
think i would love to take credit for
all of it but it's not me for
unfortunately it's just me following
nature yeah
and yeah sleeping with your children i
mean if you were in a for if you were in
a in
any kind of um wild setting
where they're animals if you put your
baby over there your baby's going to get
eaten
so it's not ideal for the baby to be
over there that's how i thought too like
back when i was get first like gonna
have elvis like the topic of co-sleeping
or crib or anything like that i'm like
but if i was like sleeping outside in a
tent i wouldn't put him in a separate
tent no like no way
and their little bodies are designed to
have milk ever they they're they need
that milk every two hours when they're
building up and you know their baby
their bellies are too tiny and it
actually makes you sleep so much better
i remember when i first had bear i would
get up
to go breastfeed him he was still in bed
with me but i would get up i don't know
why i would just you know i was a new
mom so yeah get up
and then one of my friends said why are
you doing that just roll over yes i was
like oh yeah oh yeah but my boobs aren't
quite big enough i don't think i had the
big the big ones that could kind of get
in there as well but i start i started
and it does save a lot and then i would
find
that you'd be asleep you'd be on one
side and then you'd wake up and you're
like how do you get on that side because
i didn't
you know but um
but i just think it's delicious i think
being a mom is the most precious most
like unbelievable experience in this
world and it's not for everyone and you
know anybody who doesn't want to do it
shouldn't do it but for me
i just
it's so divine it's and i wanted to
savor every moment of his life and
that's why i didn't i wanted to have
more but then my my relationship got
messed up and then it was not a great
time to bring one in but i didn't want
to have one right away because i was so
in love with my bear i wanted to every
squeeze every little moment out of him
so it wasn't until he was like three
that i was ready to make another baby
and then i didn't have partners so
so that's why i don't have four babies
but i would i wouldn't probably want
four babies but i would definitely want
two or three yeah um
so
but being like i would not be you ellen
no no i don't think i could do that um
but maybe maybe like you're like you
started a lot younger than i did i just
can't i feel like way older than you no
you don't seem older well i'm way older
than you so
you started younger um if i had started
younger i probably would be you
i knew that when i was little i knew i
had to wait because i thought if i start
i won't stop
and but my point is that nurturing this
little monkey and having him
you know i just wanted to do what was
healthiest for him at every turn and so
every choice i make is either built on
instinct or deep research it's not like
uh it's not like um
i'm just not gonna do this
i
i there's a book called the continuum
concept that is so beautifully written
about this psychologist who follows
these tribes and watches how the
how it's done and it's really the basis
of attachment parenting because it's
when the baby is on your body
in the field with you at all times where
you can see and hear what they need they
tell you when they need to go to the
bathroom they tell you when they need to
eat they tell you what they need and you
can address it because they're right
there yeah these children do not grow up
needing uh they're not needy they're not
i know there's a misconception a huge
misconception with like you know
attachment parenting positive parenting
that it makes your kids like
needy or insecure fiercely independent
it's actually the opposite because they
feel more secure yeah that's at least
what i've found for sure and the thing
about co-slipping another thing to touch
on a lot of people will have this fear
because of what maybe the media or other
things are telling you that like it's
unsafe or whatever doctors but a lot of
times it's not really showing the
balance of both sides like hey look the
times when there is something that's
unsafe is generally when a mom is either
drinking or on medication yes for sure
and so or anyone in the bed like so no
one in the bed should be on medication
yeah that information if you are
not on medication altering your state
yes like you are so aware even though
like you said even though like you said
you are you are asleep you sleep so well
but there's something deep in you that
is so hyper aware you wouldn't that'll
never go away some other yeah it would
never go away for sure and like you said
that you're so obsessed with your baby
like i just think about little ko facts
and i'm just obsessed with him when i
look at his little face and i'm just
like what did you do you're just so cute
it's so true because when i talk to
someone who doesn't have any children
sometimes they're like oh might be like
afraid or nervous while they're holding
a baby and i'm like but once you give
birth that all goes away like it's like
this is my baby yeah and it's like that
inner primal yeah and it's so natural to
just want to do that like keeping your
baby close and yeah and follow your
intuition with that well bear and i
still sleep together wow yeah so that's
another thing like all the all the stuff
and i'll be in trouble for saying that
but i don't really care you did
elimination communication oh that's
amazing elimination communication is the
best well so i never did that i remember
when you got to do it with your new baby
i remember you were like you told last
time when that was
i know you like rave about it and my
sister is just getting into it it's so
easy tell her tell her but her baby is
older now like she was waiting she
waited he's like he's older and so she's
like won't work but he's but right but
he's actually already showing because
diapers generally help babies like feel
they're wet yeah yeah earlier all of our
kids like learned to go on the potty
like but by the time they were two
that's great yeah except for co-facts
we've been you know we have too many
kids now yeah you have a lot of kids not
too many not too many we have a lot of
kids and so the the ability to like help
like census queues is a little bit
harder i could see that but you could
just do it every time so what you could
start with is when they're little right
when the baby comes out yeah right when
that baby comes out start with
don't put the pressure on yourself of
watching his cues you have five children
yeah for goodness sakes that's going to
be impossible
but what you could do is every time
you're done feeding the baby put the
baby over the toilet
and did you just go
and did you did you just not put diapers
on him at all so i didn't i came to it
too late so if i'm if i ever got to have
another baby in my life i would start
right away i feel like you will i
started with at six months
and so you're a little bit late to the
game yeah but bear never went poop in a
diaper again after eight months wow
eight months that's amazing so the way
what i would do because he was just
grabbed for the toilet because he
already knew that that's where you go
poo poo yeah and i never had to tr this
wasn't training it wasn't there was no
crying this was just simply
when i was done feeding him
he would go to the bathroom on the
toilet and when i when he woke up from a
nap he'd go to the toilet and so those
are two simple cues and they happen a
lot you know babies wake up a lot and
babies eat a lot so if you just practice
putting them to the bathroom after that
that will knock out like half your
diaper usage
and um
but no i didn't like when we went on an
airplane or if he was sleeping he still
had a diaper on right cloth diaper yeah
but um
or i think even when we traveled we
would do real diapers because we
couldn't deal with the you know
traveling with your cloth and then yeah
what do you do with them yeah so we
would use the the environmentally kind
ones um
but uh
no and i there was a period of time
where i was watching him naked and
waiting like he's watching the queues
the cues part for me was
really fun because i thought that he was
flirting with me because he would do
this little smile
but that's when he had to pee
but they give you a cue so once you
figure out the cue yeah but i can
understand with for coming right five
children that would be difficult but you
may yeah yes but i might give it a go
i'll let you know we'll see thanks for
the tips i remember my husband
christopher when i first was doing it
i've been there and i'd be going
what is this hippie [ __ ] you're doing
now and then i said just try it and he
loved it he was like this works that's
so funny well a lot of it comes down to
the disconnection that we have with our
modern society everything so fast and
like go go go and you know the plastic
diapers actually affects their ability
to even feel their pee
and my sister was reading a book and she
i don't know if this is true but she
read a book and she told me that in the
book it explained how in the 50s back
before like
was it the 1950s i could be wrong on the
decade but um back before like plastic
diapers were around like babies potty
trained by the time they were a year and
a half on average um because they were
in cloth diapers or because there was
like more motivation for the parents to
get them because it was more of a pain
to wash diapers back then and then now
the average age of the child's potty
trained is three
what a difference and it comes with such
suffering i mean what i really notice is
the suffering that people go through the
conversations you hear parents having
about like oh my god we've been working
there it's like it's causing such strife
in their household all because of the
convenience yeah of that period of time
of having them poo and pee in something
that's so uncomfortable yeah what you've
done is trained your baby that that's
where they go
you trained them that yeah so how are
you gonna now you have to untrain them
from that and that's a hard journey
that's a bit insightful you told them
that this is where you go
and so if you tell them that that's
where they go then you have to retrain
them to do something else and that's
struggle yeah cause that was a safe
place for them since they were a baby
i've never heard it said like that like
you you trained them to do like this is
where you're yeah because women and
women in other cultures
their babies are like there's a
particular um group of women in china
who have their babies on their back
while they're working yes and the babies
just go like this they tighten and they
know that when their babies tighten on
the legs that it's time to put them it's
not like they go instantly yeah they
give you the babies are so well designed
they did it did it so right they have a
there's a there's a period of time you
have a minute because you think it's
like you have no time
but it's not you have from the moment
they give you the cue
or the flirt or whatever it is for you
there's a you have a grace period of
about i don't know how long it is but
let's say it's a minute or two yeah as
long as i know you're on it you can get
them out and they'll go
and it's really beautiful that's
inspiring you might have changed my mind
about it i tried to do it with my dog i
kind of worked on my dog when i rescued
pinto bean i was like
now i have to teach him how to do it and
i just set a timer
and um did the same thing i was like
okay he's every five minutes i'm gonna
take him out to pee because he was a
baby he was eight weeks
and he had pneumonia when he came to me
and he weren't sure he was gonna live
that's why i took him but he lived yeah
miso soup and brown rice
and then uh
and then i would graduate to like 10
minutes and then 15 minutes and he's
never gone in the house he's it was so
great but it was i learned that through
my pottery whispering potty whispering
for bear oh you're a pro
another thing that's anti-status quo is
kind of like the gentle respectful
parenting not punishment you've talked
about that before you talked about that
before right yeah there's there's no
i've never had a need i've never had a
need to raise my i mean there was one
time i was in the pool and something a
little dangerous happened and i said i
grabbed bear's little arm and i just
said
you may not do that
and he went mommy why are you yelling at
me oh i said baby i'm not yelling he
goes but you're so serious i said i am
serious wow this is serious we're in a
pool
and you may not do that yeah he goes
okay yeah
and that was our communication yeah
because it's so true that he's used to
your respectful way of speaking to him
so if there was something super serious
you're still being respectful but being
serious he's like whoa that's very
serious but if that's how you're always
talking then it's like a lot of times
you have the whole why do i have to yell
at them ten times they still don't
listen to me that's how you're always
talking to them they're just gonna be
like whatever yeah i never yell at him
and i say sorry a lot i do too so if i
you know if i am feeling stressed
because you know for example if bear
comes home from school and i'm trying to
cook dinner get it help him with his
homework the dogs are going crazy and
i've got work calls coming in or any
variation on that above
you know which can be any given day if i
haven't slept well because i ate crap
the night before or whatever yeah right
or i'm having my period then i might be
a little bit more prickly now i'm still
not yelling yeah i'm just simply not as
available and i am really i don't i'm
sensitive so i don't like a lot going on
at once so if bear is talking to me i
want to listen you talked about the
beginning your kid's feeling like i
listen to them
like i genuinely
otherwise it's noise and the noise
freaks me out
i'm either with you or i want you away
like it's i can't yeah i can't have this
sort of
chaos
so if bears talking to me and i'm trying
to get the dinner ready i can't i'm
sometimes not equipped to do both
sometimes i'm like i can't dinner's
never gonna get ready so i'll just say
bear i'm so sorry mommy's not able to do
both things right now at the same time
can we can you write down all the
stories you want to tell me and i can't
wait to hear them as soon as i'm done
making the dinner yeah and he's like
okay yeah and it works and then he goes
and does his thing he'll play legos or
he'll work on his school project or
he'll be reading or whatever he's doing
and and i don't put him on the tv i do
not do media
and and i can do this thing and
sometimes in the process over the years
he's forgotten there's been times when
he was literally lit more little and
he'd come in and go but mommy and i'd go
okay great i'm gonna write down what's
that story about okay bananas great
bananas we're gonna write that one down
and all the stories because i just i
really
want to be available and present
it's such precious time i don't want to
lose it
but i also have to make dinner yeah so i
know that both things have to happen i
want to be available and present but i
have to make dinner
so the choice right and so we make
dinner and then during dinner he tells
me all the stories and then at bath time
he tells me all the stories and then all
the stories get out
and um and i think it's it's really
been amazing he respects me because i
respect him i remember being a kid and
being told you must respect me and me
going
but
you haven't earned that yeah this is not
behavior that earns respect you're scary
you're mean
you're being an awful person right so
you can't demand it you shouldn't demand
it you should it should be
um
a gift that they give you because of the
way you are with them
yes right absolutely it's it's what you
embody and then they naturally want to
embody that too yeah because you are the
example they're like mirrors for us how
we treat them is how they're going to
treat us yeah and i'm not perfect at it
you know there are times where that's
when the story comes in where i'll feel
like a little bit
i just don't like my voice as much like
i don't like that that sounds a little
not happy or i'm having a tone or i'm
being short i'm being short and so i'll
just i'll go sit down with him and i'll
just say bear i just want to let you
know mommy's not feeling good at all
right now and so i'm being a bit i don't
like how i sound because it's okay mommy
yeah okay i'm glad you're okay with it
but i just want you know that mommy
doesn't like this isn't my favorite
mommy this is like this is my not his
favorite mommy but she'll be back yeah
because i know i know he knows oh that's
so great i know any time that i do say
sorry to my kids which is a lot cause i
mess up a lot um it's just you feel they
they appreciate it so much they feel so
loved and heard yeah and it it goes it
creates safety so much safety because if
you when you grow up in a house where
they have no they don't take any
responsibility for what they do
and there's
no awareness of how their actions affect
other people
it's almost it's crazy making you really
don't have a sense
of what's okay you don't know what
you're
it's very difficult to know yourself and
to know what's okay
and so when you're giving a child the
opportunity to go oh yeah i'm it's okay
for me to be upset sometimes it's okay
for me to be tired sometimes or to
i've even have bears say to me mommy in
case i seem a little tired or grumpy i
just feel a little funny right now and i
go you you're perfect and he's like okay
but you know he's he's doing what you're
used to what i'm doing he's not feeling
good i love perfect self that's so good
well he's amazing you guys are so great
together so what just to round out this
conversation what are you working on now
tell us about your podcast so that my
audience can go listen to your podcast
and then also how's your my kind organic
supplements going
and also we didn't even really mention
what your book is called like your like
the kind diet maybe just talk about that
okay thank you yeah so
the first thing was the kind diet i
wrote that a long time ago and i love
this book so much and
um there's really delicious food in
there because i'm a food snob so there's
it's not about like boring gross food
it's delicious
and
it's really a book about helping you to
make even if the book is for people i'm
sure most of your audience is probably
more on board with us but let's let's
hope there are some people out there who
are not yeah this is um this is a book
that would help you to just make choices
for yourself and you don't have it's not
you don't have to go all the way it's
really about like there's a flirting
version
there's vegan and then there's superhero
so it really breaks down sort of how i
see food in terms of these are all the
reasons for the earth for the animals
being kind to yourself being kind to
your the animals being kind to um
the earth did i say that the animals
your body all of those things and so
really getting the information it's just
being informed and then you can make
whatever choice you want you don't have
to go full-on you can just dabble in it
you might choose to eliminate one
creature and not the other whatever
but i think it's a book full of great
information and then there's a book the
kind mama that if you're trying to get
pregnant
and you are having a hard time it's a
definite must read it's a beautiful book
and i love how it has so you have so
many things it's not just about like
what to eat there's so many things yeah
well because i really felt like this is
the book i wished i had when i was
pregnant yeah you know there was there's
so many books and it's just i personally
think they're all a waste of time to
read you know there's some that are
probably good but the majority of the
the books on the market the mainstream
books they're just it's like ridiculous
yeah information and it's so
unhealthy and unnatural and so i
i just the book really
brings you back to primal parenting
trusting your instincts and
knowing well i have choices here if i'm
trying so the book is for if you're
trying to get pregnant it will help
boost your fertility once you are
pregnant how to not have all that icky
you know the stuff that people come to
accept as normal which is not normal
being gassy bloated um
having hemorrhoids having diabetes
having swollen ankles being really moody
all of that stuff is not that's not what
happens because you get pregnant
it's not you don't have to have it that
way you know oh my gosh
exactly i feel really really great when
i'm pregnant i just love how vibrant i
feel i feel really well my assistant is
like i always forget you're pregnant
like you're the least pregnant pregnant
person i know right
yeah because i just feel so good yes i
had a friend lalania who when she was
she gave birth that night but she walked
into real food daily this restaurant in
la
and she's vegan and healthy and her eyes
were white and she was just popping out
happy glowy like not in any rush to have
this baby
and i just was like how pregnant are you
right now she's just floating you know
goddess-like and that was my example you
know i had examples like that around me
and then that's how i was
christopher would say to people my
wife's pregnant and they go oh she's
miserable like oh god is she just
driving you crazy does she want that
baby out he'd say no none of those
things i love it it's such a special
time it is so that's the kind mama and
it helps you to know what you need and
don't need because they tell you you
need all this stuff and you don't need
very much and it's also after baby's
born too yeah it takes you through six
months so it's really about
thinking about having a baby then you
need to read it and then it takes you
all the way to like six about six months
yep
and then the my kind organics are doing
great they are the first ever non-gmo
verified certified organic not um
all food based no fillers no binders
just food vitamins
and they continue to do great and people
seem to really be happy that they have
them and people are always telling me
stories pregnant women tell me about how
the prenatals are the only ones that
don't make them sick
and i say that's so good and
and the kids gummies the kids love them
these are so delicious and then the
sprays it's really hard to get your kids
not to spray themselves they want to
spray that the b12 non-stop
they're just bringing their face they're
just
non-stop it's so cute but um anyway
those are doing great and i'm i'm i was
just really proud to make something that
would be healthy for us because our when
i was pregnant my midwife said i should
take a prenatal and i thought why like i
first of all eat so well and then also
there's nothing clean out there to take
and you would assume if it's a vitamin
it would be clean to take but they're
not if you read the ingredients
so
i made one
and then that was what happened so you
just made it i made them i went made
them i thought i have to partner with
somebody and make these so that i can
have them and my friends can have them
and everyone can have something clean
and healthy that they can feel good
about that is responsibly made with
organic farmers i mean all the way to
who where the soil and the farmers and
everything it's it's really good um
and then
what else and then oh your podcast my
podcast is called the real heel
and i'm really just looking at asking
the questions what is it really going to
take for us to heal our bodies
our communities ourselves and um and our
pla and our planet that we live on
and
that's the question i'm sort of asking
of all of my guests in all different
ways we have really cool guests like
pinky cole who is working to heal food
deserts in atlanta through her [ __ ]
vegan
burger shop which is so good and when
you go in there you get such a vibe i
need to go there it's so good where is
it it's in atlanta oh yeah
but it it's and it's in this community
where it's really a food desert where
people have disregarded them don't you
know they don't they don't care and so
she's gone in there and created this
place and she's playing pumping music
everyone in there is her family they're
so happy and spunky and anyway it's a
great vibe and um and then kevin smith
who you know is this icon for pop
culture he almost died of a crazy heart
attack and how he cured himself with his
food and his daughter did that to him
and he's this happy vibrant man
and um and mackie shelton who is the
coach to serena williams and um
venus williams and well i think he's
serena's coach but venus and serena are
very close as their sisters
so helping them with their food
and who else is excited ed begley jr is
so adorable my dear friend mary walden
who's a therapist in chicago talks about
love and self-love and how we do that
how to make it practical real change in
our lives for healing for ourselves so
it really starts with healing yourself
and then healing your children and it
sort of expands as we go on and yeah
talk to see spirit sees um yeah yeah ali
he that film is so incredible and really
i learned so much i did not know after
seeing that so i'm just having fun
learning and talking to people that i
admire and sharing this information with
people me too that's why i started
podcasting like you want to just sit
down like what can i learn from you what
can i be inspired by which i definitely
feel that way about you so thank you for
all that you do and thank you so much
for coming on the podcast i will put a
link below for everyone listening or
watching
to find all of her things her book her
supplements there's a website too that's
kind life that kind of
shows it all yes but i'll definitely
link your podcast thank you please yes
okay all right thanks everybody for
being here
and have a great day
[Music]